I want to be honest with you man New
York really [ __ ] me up that's why I'm
a little weird right now I'm gonna be
real with it I didn't have some good
shows in New York what do you consider
not a good show because I've seen you
there was nine people in my third show I
was gonna say anything because I'm
embarrassed by it I think that we can I
have to confront my reality look it was
a 12:30 show midnight it doesn't matter
when all the details those what are the
details oh it's one of my characters
thank you so can I just say this okay
this is that I know that my ticket
numbers since January I've been amazing
yeah yeah amazing dude it's like
Saturday night New York 12:30 there was
nine people and then I walk up to the
manager and I go hey do I have to do 45
minutes do a show yeah I go can we
cancel it
no contractually though I get that
because those people did pay $22 to see
so of course that's they were all Tiger
belly fans thank god that's good you're
amazing and and without them obviously
there'd be no show so I thank you for
coming out but dude it was really
humbling my question is you know in
anticipation if let's say I'm like a
club owner and I see that oh only nine
people have bought tickets for a 12:30
show wouldn't I just cancel that show
and form those nine people but that
there's an earlier show with still nine
seats available pushed shut down the
club early and you know save money on
electricity on not paying you know they
have shows downstairs that's why I see
something right so does the things open
right already
you know and it's also it's like you
know that's the comedy that's what I'm
gonna say is that it's comedy it's life
and it's New York and there's a lot of
competition and it's not that it's just
that like it's like I've done this game
you know just a little reprieve you know
every year it's like audition not
getting it this that and then your
friends become you know and that's like
you just went a little
propre you just went a little like a
year or you're just kind of like you
know you know I'm fine you know every
year is a [ __ ] battle it's like every
day the battle you know it's like other
I just gonna say it it's like man up
cloud sniper tonight what Wow man up
baby sack the [ __ ] up
quit your bitching you make good money
of a roof over you head roof you have me
your friends you have Tiger belly you
have your three cats were good we get
fed all right all right yeah I wasn't
really crying by the wipe away by the Y
okay I was just doing a fake cry called
acting you know I was called acting guys
yeah showcasing my abilities you know
[Music]